Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Mary Andrews Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Today we are going to be thinking about outcome measures. And in case you're not sure, outcome measures are questionnaires or ways of us gathering data about people to be able to use firstly as a baseline so we know where people are currently on their level of functioning and then secondly we might do them mid-intervention and then we might do them at the end of the intervention and if you're working in perhaps in an IAPT service you will be well versed in outcome measures because some services they ask clients to do outcome measures every single session and certainly when I worked in a CAM service, we also used to like to use outcome measures to see how well aligned the session was to the client's needs.
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。今天我们要探讨的是“结果测量”（outcome measures）。如果你不确定这是什么，结果测量就是问卷或收集数据的方式，我们首先将其作为基准，了解人们目前的运作水平，然后可能在干预中期和干预结束时再次进行测量。如果你在IAPT（心理治疗改善获取）服务机构工作，你一定很熟悉结果测量，因为有些服务机构要求客户每次会谈都进行测量。当然，当我还在CAM（儿童与青少年心理健康）服务机构工作时，我们也喜欢使用结果测量来观察会谈与客户需求的契合度。
And I will level with you, that one could feel a little cringy, you know, asking, how was it for you? How did I do? And, you know, it's whether it's entirely valid, asking someone to your face, you know, how was I? So the way that I gather outcome data about myself as a clinician is that my virtual assistant, Hannah, tends to ask clients for me and then they email her. Just kind of puts a little bit more, I don't know, not confidentiality, because, of course, Hannah would know who had sent the feedback through. But it just feels like people can be, you know, honest um if things haven't met their needs ideally um you know so it just feels maybe slightly less I don't know narcissistic to ask Hannah to ask uh on my behalf you know how we're doing as a service um I know in a service I
我跟你说实话，有时候问“这对你来说感觉如何？我做得怎么样？”会让人觉得有点尴尬。而且，当面问别人“我表现如何”是否完全有效也值得商榷。因此，作为临床医生，我收集关于自己的结果数据的方式是：我的虚拟助理Hannah会代我询问客户，然后他们通过电子邮件回复她。这感觉稍微多了一点……我不知道，不是保密性，因为Hannah当然知道是谁发来的反馈。但这样感觉人们可以更诚实，如果某些方面没有达到他们的需求。所以，让Hannah代我询问我们作为服务机构的表现，感觉没那么……我不知道，没那么自恋。
previously worked in we used to have something called Feedback Wednesday which was every Wednesday anyone coming through the service was given a questionnaire by reception as they arrived and asked to kind of fill it out after their appointment and just drop it in a box and it could be anonymous if you wanted it to be and that's a really useful way of gathering data about services but in terms of what I do so I work in largely adult mental health I would say so the measures I use don't screen necessarily for things like psychosis and don't screen for you know memory. I'm looking at kind of depression, anxiety, you know, trauma, to come up with an idea of how someone is functioning, you know, whether their well-being is impacted upon, whether they have any risk to themselves or others and and you know how many problems they've got
我之前工作过的一个机构，我们有一种叫“反馈星期三”的活动。每个星期三，任何来到机构的人在接待处都会收到一份问卷，并在预约结束后填写，然后投入箱子里。如果你愿意，这可以是匿名的。这是收集服务数据的一种非常有用的方式。但就我个人而言，我主要从事成人心理健康工作，所以我使用的测量工具不一定用于筛查精神病或记忆力问题。我关注的是抑郁、焦虑、创伤等，以了解一个人的运作情况，了解他们的幸福感是否受到影响，他们对自己或他人是否有风险，以及他们有多少问题。
really so that measure is nicely represented by the core CORE which is freely available so technically it's called the core OM so the core outcome measure and that's a series of 34 questions and um you know they cover all of those aspects functioning problems well-being and risk um and it covers like the last week um from when people are filling it in um and you know the options would be not at all only occasionally sometimes often or most or all of the time uh and some of the questions are negatively weighted so that they you know so that you are mixing it up a little bit and of course if you're asking someone about a positive thing um and they feel that most or all of the time then that would be like a zero score
所以，这个测量工具由CORE（临床结果常规评估）很好地代表了，它是免费提供的。从技术上讲，它被称为CORE-OM，即核心结果测量。这是一系列包含34个问题的问卷，涵盖了运作、问题、幸福感和风险等所有方面。它涵盖了人们填写问卷前一周的情况。选项包括“完全没有”、“偶尔”、“有时”、“经常”或“大部分/所有时间”。其中一些问题是负向加权的，这样可以混合一下。当然，如果你问的是积极的事情，而他们觉得大部分或所有时间都是这样，那得分就是零。
whereas if it was something negative and the answer was most or all of the time, then that would be like a zero score. Whereas if it was something negative and the answer was most or all of the time, then that would be a score of four. So when I was an assistant, I designed a spreadsheet using Excel to automatically score this, which I still use and yeah some of my supervisors across the time have used it as well because they've liked it because they can be a little fiddly to score so the way that I've done it is that it just means that you pop in the answers you know your numerical answers 1 to 34 with either 0 1 2 3 or 4 and then it will automatically tell you whether things are clinically significant and if they are you know where their levels of you know impact are most keenly felt and they'll do some whizzy little graphs as well so yeah that's the kind of thing I used to get up to when I was you know when I was an aspiring clinical psychologist. So yeah, so they're a useful
而如果是负面的事情，答案是“大部分或所有时间”，那得分就是四分。所以当我还是助理时，我用Excel设计了一个电子表格来自动评分，我现在还在用。是的，我的一些主管在过去也用过它，因为他们觉得手动评分有点麻烦。我的做法是，你只需输入1到34题的数值答案（0、1、2、3或4），它就会自动告诉你情况是否具有临床意义，如果确实如此，你会知道他们的影响水平在哪里最强烈，它还会生成一些精美的图表。所以，这就是我还在做有抱负的临床心理学家时会做的事情。所以，它们确实是有用的测量工具。
measure. So I would do those along with the GAD-7, which is an anxiety measure, and the PHQ-9. I also quite like the ACE scale, which is the Adverse Child childhood experience scale. Now I often send all of my measures ahead of time through my clinical software called WriteUp so people can do them in the comfort of their own home before our first session but I actually don't send the ACE scale so if you're familiar with the ACE scale it's all about the first 18 years of life and covers trauma. And some of the questions, you know, they're not that nice. You know, it's about domestic violence. It's about sexual abuse. It's about physical violence and harm. And so I don't want to flood clients with that um and i think what i will do is i maybe will do a special podcast episode
我会将这些测量与GAD-7（焦虑测量）和PHQ-9（抑郁测量）一起使用。我也很喜欢ACE量表，即“不良童年经历量表”。我通常会通过我的临床软件WriteUp提前发送所有测量问卷，这样人们可以在第一次会谈前在舒适的家中完成。但我实际上不会发送ACE量表。如果你熟悉ACE量表，它全是关于生命前18年的经历，涵盖了创伤。其中一些问题……并不那么令人愉快。它涉及家庭暴力、性虐待、身体暴力和伤害。所以我不想用这些来冲击客户。我想我以后会专门做一期播客节目。
on adverse childhood experiences and you know how they show up for our clients and how they can be indicated so i'll do that as a as a special feature um with perhaps some disclaimers about some of the stuff i'll be saying in it but I think that's probably going to be a better use of our time rather than just laboring the points on the eight scale here. So why do we monitor this information? Well primarily it's because we want to know like I said we want to know where clients are starting's because we want to know, like I said, we want to know where clients are starting. But also, we want to know that what we are doing, you know, the approaches that we said would be helpful, are in fact helpful. And if they're not making shifts, then it's a really good chance for us to see, you know, what the barriers are, what's getting in the way of those clients making
专门讨论不良童年经历，以及它们如何体现在我们的客户身上，以及如何识别它们。我会把它作为一个专题，并附上一些关于我所讲内容的免责声明。但我认为这比在这里纠结ACE量表的细节更有意义。那么，我们为什么要监测这些信息呢？主要是因为我们想知道，正如我所说，我们想知道客户的起点在哪里。但我们也想知道我们所做的事情，即我们认为有帮助的方法，是否真的有帮助。如果他们没有改变，那么这是一个很好的机会让我们看看障碍是什么，是什么阻碍了客户取得进展。
progress. And it might be that, you know, it can be really useful to look at Maslow's hierarchy. So I'll often look at that with clients when I'm thinking about formulation, just to get an idea of where they're at. So for those of you who are not familiar with Maslow's hierarchy it's a full title is the Maslow's hierarchy of needs and it's like a multi-colored pyramid with at the bottom the safety and risk needs you know emotional love needs and as it goes up and up and up the you know know, as it would with the pyramid, it gets smaller and smaller. And the bit right on top would be self-actualization. So, you know, what you might be doing now by listening to this podcast is self-actualization. Let's just use this
查看马斯洛需求层次理论可能非常有用。在考虑个案构思时，我经常会和客户一起查看这个理论，以了解他们处于什么阶段。对于那些不熟悉马斯洛需求层次理论的人，它的全称是“马斯洛需求层次”，它像一个多色的金字塔，底部是安全和风险需求，然后是情感和爱，随着层级向上，金字塔变得越来越小。最顶端是自我实现。所以，你们现在听这个播客可能就是在进行自我实现。让我们利用这段时间休息一下。
time now to have a short break, and I will be help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Hi, my name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical
我将帮助你获得资格。来看看这本书吧，它就是《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。你好，我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的不同故事非常有趣。我惊讶于通往这一目标的途径竟然如此之多，没有完美的路径。这让我充满信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心。
psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. clinical psychologist collective hi welcome back so self-actualization um yes that is what we are doing now we are furthering our development needs which comes in the self-actualization category and you know if you were for example supporting a client who was trying to access you know a higher education course but they you know were sofa surfing or they were in a domestically
一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。来看看这本书吧，它就是《临床心理学家集体》。你好，欢迎回来。所以，自我实现……是的，这就是我们现在正在做的事情，我们正在提升我们的发展需求，这属于自我实现范畴。如果你正在支持一位试图参加高等教育课程的客户，但他们居无定所，或者处于家庭暴力关系中，或者没有足够的钱买食物，你可能会注意到他们很难投入、集中注意力并从高等教育课程中真正受益。
violent relationship or you know they didn't have enough money for food what you might well notice is that they would struggle to engage and pay attention and really benefit from that higher education course and in the same way if they've got all of those you know emotional turmoil needs but also you know physical safety and you know where am I going to sleep tonight that takes center stage and so any work with you to do kind of therapy or processing is just it's probably going to be set, you know, set up to fail. So it can mean that you're having slightly difficult conversations with people that now might not be the right time, which is really tricky because people are are like well i really like you you know i really trust you and i you know i want to i want to get better um and you're like i know i know you do um and you know you're really moved with their distress um but we're not necessarily
同样，如果他们有所有那些情感动荡的需求，还有身体安全需求，以及“我今晚睡在哪里”的问题，这些会占据中心位置。所以，任何试图进行治疗或处理的工作都可能会以失败告终。这意味着你可能不得不与人们进行一些稍微困难的对话，告诉他们现在可能不是合适的时机。这真的很棘手，因为人们会说“我真的很喜欢你，我很信任你，我想好起来”，而你会说“我知道，我知道你想”。你会被他们的痛苦所触动，但我们不一定能……
closing to all services you know in an ideal world we might be able to to refer to you know other relevant local services and that might be you know shelter for helping with homelessness or you know the local housing office crisis team or you know a refuge someone that helps with domestic violence you know because actually they've got more pressing needs and in
关闭所有服务。在理想的世界里，我们也许能够转介到其他相关的当地服务机构，比如帮助解决无家可归问题的收容所，或者当地的住房办公室危机小组，或者帮助解决家庭暴力问题的避难所。因为实际上，他们有更紧迫的需求。
monopoly style, pass go and collect their 200 pounds, if you what I mean so yeah that's all useful functions of outcome measures but another really nice function is when you're able to sit with a client and show them how far they've come and that makes you as a clinician feel pretty good as well. You know, you've taken someone from really struggling, you know, really not thriving, really finding every day, you know, challenging. You know, they might be really low in mood. They might be having ideas of life not being worth living they might be you know really struggling with their functioning and you know these things that you can't measure would be changes in facial expression changes in how engaged the person seems so we have this um you know concept called flat effect and that's when someone just doesn't really move their face much you know they're not they're not super expressive and you know to begin with people can be really
像大富翁游戏一样，通过起点并领取200英镑，你懂我的意思吗？所以，这些都是结果测量的有用功能。但另一个非常好的功能是，当你能够坐下来向客户展示他们走了多远时，这也会让你作为临床医生感觉很好。你把一个处于挣扎中、没有蓬勃发展、觉得每一天都充满挑战的人带了出来。他们的情绪可能非常低落，可能有过生命不值得活的想法，他们的运作可能非常困难。而那些你无法测量的事情，比如面部表情的变化、参与度的变化。我们有一个概念叫“情感平淡”，就是指一个人的面部表情不多，他们不是特别有表现力。起初，人们可能非常……
understandably problem focused and can seem a little trickier to engage and as the intervention starts to shift as their world starts to open up again, they become more interested in you as a person as well. So watch out for, you know, clients saying, well, how are you? You know, are you all right? Because they, you know, they like you, hopefully. That's why they're continuing to come back to sessions, either virtually or in person. You're a key part of the intervention so i'm absolutely on board with roger's uh principles about um you know us being our therapeutic relationship and ourselves being one of the most key parts of the intervention because if they don't like you they ain't coming back you know and so I absolutely think that a
可以理解地专注于问题，可能看起来更难参与。但随着干预开始转变，随着他们的世界再次打开，他们也会对你这个人更感兴趣。所以要注意客户说“你好吗？你还好吗？”因为他们喜欢你，希望如此。这就是为什么他们会继续回来参加会谈，无论是线上的还是线下的。你是干预的关键部分。所以我完全赞同罗杰斯的原则，即我们的治疗关系和我们自己是干预中最关键的部分之一。因为如果他们不喜欢你，他们就不会再来了。所以我绝对认为以人为本的互动是正确的方式。
human first interaction is the way to go and my training most definitely you know taught me more about using more of myself in therapy appropriately of course But I have done a psychodynamic placement within training, which meant that, you know, you very much play your cards close to your chest. But since qualifying, I really, you know, think I'm much more confident with being human, human and certainly discovering and exploring the compassion focused approach really helps me not only be my authentic self but um you know just be warm engaging and non-judgmental as well so it really helps me to bring those core you know aspects of the Rogerian theory into into my practice and you know I think when people meet me on the street um you know I'm not that different um in person I might shower my kids a bit less
我的训练确实教会了我更多关于在治疗中适当地使用更多自我的知识。当然，我在训练中做过心理动力学实习，这意味着你必须非常谨慎。但自从获得资格后，我真的认为我在做人方面更有信心了。当然，发现和探索以同情为中心的疗法确实帮助我不仅能做真实的自己，而且还能保持温暖、投入和不评判。所以它确实帮助我将罗杰斯理论的核心方面带入我的实践中。我想当人们在街上遇到我时，我并没有什么不同。在个人生活中，我可能对孩子少一点……
how annoying children can be can't they um Especially at bedtime. I don't know if you've got kids but lately mine are pushing it a little bit at bedtime running into each other's bedrooms the little rogues. So yeah just because you're a psychologist it doesn't make you a wonder parent because no such thing exists. So yeah just to recap I do use outcome measures and when I've been in every service I've worked in I like a bit of data I like to be able to demonstrate that changes are happening some services of course you know once you've made those changes on the measures you are out you're out of there so it's useful to know the data but really i think we need to be in a position where we are embracing data as clinical psychologists we're not shying away from it
孩子们有多烦人，不是吗？特别是在睡觉时间。不知道你有没有孩子，但最近我的孩子在睡觉时间有点过分，跑进对方的卧室，这些小淘气。所以，仅仅因为你是心理学家并不意味着你就是完美的父母，因为这种东西根本不存在。所以，总结一下，我确实使用结果测量。在我工作过的每一个服务机构中，我都喜欢数据，我喜欢能够证明变化正在发生。当然，有些服务机构一旦你在测量上做出了改变，你就完成了。所以了解数据很有用，但我真的认为我们需要处于一种作为临床心理学家拥抱数据的状态，而不是回避它。
and with the you know the technological advances we've had lately it doesn't need to be paper heavy so you absolutely can find electronic ways of doing this and getting the data back to you and storing the data if it is obviously compliant with whatever your organizational policies are on that. I hope you found this useful. As ever, if you've got any questions about anything, just give me a shout and I'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode very soon take care bye It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
随着我们最近取得的技术进步，它不需要纸张繁重。所以你绝对可以找到电子方式来完成这些工作，并将数据传回给你，并存储数据，只要它显然符合你所在组织的任何政策。希望你觉得这很有用。一如既往，如果你有任何问题，尽管告诉我，我期待很快在下一期节目中与你见面。保重，再见。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Yana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现书中关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的不同故事非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我惊讶于通往这一目标的途径竟然如此之多，没有完美的路径。这让我充满信心，觉得我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。